this will be by Meccano thank you and
thank you to the organizer of the
workshop so I am currently a positive UC
Berkeley but most of this work I did at
UC Santa Cruz with with my collaborators
Manfred Rommel who's here and at UC
Santa Cruz and Daniel Hsu at Columbia
University so I'll be talking about
unbiased estimates for linear regression
via volume something ok so let's start
with with a basic with a just basic
motivating example we're all familiar
with least squares regression we get a
bunch of a bunch of points X I each of
them has an Associated real label Y I
would like to fit a line through it for
simplicity for now let's assume it's
one-dimensional example so the least
squares solution says ok let's minimize
the total square loss we get this good
green line that sort of fitting the data
ok so here's here's the twist
so let's say we have the input points X
I but we the the labels Y are unknown to
us or hidden from us so so now the song
we can query for a point x i for the
label to be reviewed so now the question
is how many labels do we need to query
if that's expensive how many label how
many labels do we need to create to get
a meaningful approximation of the of the
musical solution and what is the
smallest number that can give give us a
meaningful answer so it turns out in
this case one label is enough so that
means is if we so we query one point x i
we receive one label naturally we're
going to predict with the line that goes
through that point I hear it we assuming
there's no sort of bias term in the in
your equation example right so the line
goes to the origin point and it turns
out that we can show if properly chosen
X I then the this blue estimate from
just one point is with the loss of that
estimate on the whole data set is when a
factor of two of the loss of the
to investment based on all of the
samples so how do we choose at one point
well the natural intuition is is to sort
of pick a point that has high leverage
right so it's far away from the origin
so it has big influence on there on the
green solution but if we choose it
deterministically we can run into
trouble outliers so so we want to sort
of randomize right so so here we're
going to pick a particular distribution
which picks samples one point
proportionally to the X I squared and it
turns out if we do that that has some
interesting properties so in particular
if we look at the total loss of this
blue estimate in expectation with
respect to that sampling keep in mind
that the labels you are fixed there's no
randomness in the labels so then the
expected total loss is two times the
loss of the best and that is an exact
identity also it turns out that the
expected value of that Smet itself the
blue estimate is exactly equal to the
green estimate which means that we have
an unbiased estimator of the of the
least squares regression just with
something one point with ever only ever
observing one label so naturally we can
ask how does this generalize to two more
dimensions
okay so let's set up that problem so so
right we've seen this kind of slide many
times here we have n points in the
dimensions so we have real labels Y I
the labels are hidden from us we put the
points in them in a matrix X where the
rows are the are the instances X I and
we want to minimize the total square
loss over all end points so we sample we
want to sample a bunch of points a set
of indices s right and then receive
labels for those indices so now natural
way to proceed once we have the sample
we just solve the discourse problem for
the sub sample so that can be written in
a closed form as a student in verse of
the sub matrix X sub s
well the pseudo inverse will exist
that's true so I mean yes so we will
actually be picking points in such a way
that the X sub s where is this full rank
so but good point yes if if the the the
XS campus was not full rank then you can
still write the student in this part
okay so now so now I'm gonna introduce
volume sampling so so let's recall for
for dimension one we decided that it's
reasonable to to pick a single point
with probability proportional to X I
squared right so it turns out in D
dimensions it's natural to pick D points
a subset of D points with probability
proportional to the squared determinant
of the sub-matrix right so that there's
a sort of analogue key and the intuition
here is in some sense we want to pick a
whole subset that has a high leverage
right so so that and the determinant the
interpretation of that is that it's the
so that the diamond R square is the
volume the squared volume of that
spanned by the the points or the squared
volume of the parallelepiped spun by the
the D points that the vectors the rows X
I so it kind of spreads out the points
and of course if we want a sample more
than D points this can be also naturally
generalized two sets of arbitrary size
at least D and so so so the so so this
is the volume something distribution for
the size D it first appeared in in a
paper by the shvonder of the matter and
pollen one and then the extension to
larger than e appeared in averin but cds
paper so there's this normalization here
the Z right so we're something
proportionate to the determinant of X
sub s transpose X sub s what is the
normalization it turns out it's easy to
derive using the sort of standard coffee
bean a formula which basic
the tells you what is the sum over all
the terminus all those sub matrices and
that turns out to be a factor times the
determinant of the X transpose X matrix
okay so how does the how does the result
for one dimensional case generalize to D
dimensions so we showed that for if this
volume sample add D element set s in the
regression problem discussed earlier
right so we get the points we complete
we receive the D labels we compute W
star of s the expected loss total loss
on the whole dataset of the estimator
will be exactly equal to D plus 1 times
the loss of the best and this is an
exact formula whenever X is in general
position meaning that essentially all
these subsets of points are non
degenerate this is sort of a minor
assumption and if it doesn't hold then
instead of the exactly quality you can
an upper bound which is still good and
on top of it the expectation of the
estimator itself is again equal to the
optimum estimator so if we essentially
recover the states and say statement as
before in one-dimensional case except
now we have to sample D points and the
factor sort of grow through the
dimension but again the something
distribution does not depend on the
labels and it does not depend on any
noise model of the that the result does
not depend on any noise model of the
back to Y right so it's for fixed life
yes you should expect loss you just mean
like the sum of squared errors and
there's no randomness in either the lane
exactly exactly so it's a fixed fixed
matrix X fixed vector Y you're sampling
subsets and the expectations with
respect to justice something what is
that expectation and when you choose one
point it's two if your sample with the
normal exactly any one dimension if it's
well in one point volume something is
leverage for something it's the same
thing for one point because it's just in
the norm squared that's that's what it
is right so it's the same thing if it's
it's uniform then well then you I guess
you don't get it yeah I don't know that
you get a formula or the answer question
hey the thing you're sampling is nothing
maybe I miss I thought dr. was a row
norm obey or whatever the letter you use
for the matrix wasn't in one dimension
so it's not the leopard it's wrong or
did you put it in there um well let's
see
what is what is gonna be the leopard
score in one dimension right
The effect of the so I mean back to five
unit normal and the length of the
element right so I mean so basically
it's it's the same as if your sample
according to the square so in that case
it's just so in that case the major
should be of the vector so I guess
you're not rectangular K equals one yeah
so I guess the question would make sense
if your rectangular cake was one look
take it off like is it sure okay so now
we get to so of course since we're doing
something for linear regression I have
to ask what about iid leverage across
something how does this compare how does
this fit so of course that that is
useful for this this very task we've
seen many many times here this workshop
leopard score something being used and
so what happens so so so so this is i ad
something so we define a weight for each
point and so it turns out there is a
very deep connection between average
score something and volume sampling and
specifically what so what it says here
is that the level scores are marginals a
volume something which means that if I
sample is a set according to volume
something I can ask what is the
probability of a particular row being in
that set and that probability exactly is
the level scored so so in the way I
think of it is this is another sort of
argument why levels core sampling is
natural right because it is actually in
particularly squares setting the way I
think of it is you would like to do
volume something but maybe you want to
do I so what's the natural thing to do
you go sample according to the marginals
so that's the connection but of course
there's a trade-off here if you go to
IAD something one is
you ran into the coupon collector
problem which is that you need to teach
sample dialogue the samples to get sort
of many meaningful guarantees in general
the other one is that the estimators you
get at this forum for least squares are
biased independent identically
distributed
I mean if you do something right you
sample the first point according to
lower score distribution than you sample
the second point from the same
distribution and so forth yes yes so the
first right right so you want a sample
asset right so how do you sample a set
you sample one point at a time
IAD okay so volume something sort of
takes care of both of those issues and
to show that this actually shows up in
practice just briefly let's look at a
few experiments this is a bunch of
benchmark linear regression data sets
and we can so we're comparing basically
X here's the subset size right so if our
budget is this subset size what do we
get what total loss do we get for from
the estimator and we can see that if our
budget is very restrictive the substance
ID has to be small then volume something
works much better because and you can
clearly see the coupon collector problem
in pain appearing in some cases here
writes something we waited
so when you're doing levels company
you're awaiting the divorce to
compensate for the reference notes
I mean so I'm computing the leverage
scores for every point right according
to the for another was there and then
something one point at a time according
to that district but just using to spoil
the O's and the right-hand side without
changing it without the way Oh am i we
wedding the rolls to get estimate suit
anyway the O's to the right hand side
and then compute the dance of the
regression yes so I in this case I did
reweighed the reweighed I basically did
what what you would you would want you
would normally do for leverage score
something right so I would I would
sample with this probability and then we
scaled instances right for volume
something in this case you don't need to
rescale instances okay so so why should
why should we be interested in volume
something so like I said you have some
new lost bounds which avoid coupon
collector problem now it's kind of
curious that you get exactly expectation
formula are there and if you look at it
more more carefully it turns out there's
a whole family of matrix identities
related to volume something that are
show up there yes gorgeous every scores
I just use those
and you're asking for leopard scores not
for volume right you stopped random
sampling they don't count example of one
dimension you pick the longest weight
vector it doesn't work right so if you
do if you do the term monistic sampling
right in this setting at least when y is
fixed and hidden from you you can have
adversarial vectors Y kind of are
problematic
okay so also we have this this new kind
of unbiased estimators which are sort of
useful in various settings for example
distributed settings and we want to
combine them via averaging and improve
the performance of the estimators and
also I mean volume something seems like
a sort of complicated Joint Distribution
but it has a number of very nice
properties I serve closure properties
which for example means that you can
easily sort of down sample or add
samples to a set and volume something
preserving this sort of family of
distributions which significantly helps
with the analysis so let me actually
talk about that briefly
so volume something is close under sub
something so what does that mean okay so
here's the following procedure so we
defined volume something for any fixed
size s right so we can let's say we
sample first sets of size T larger than
s and then we get subsidy we construct a
sub matrix X sub T with a volume sample
from that of size smaller s so now we
get a set s and it turns out that s is
distributed exactly according to boil
sample from the full set from the for
matrix and and that will come in handy
okay so let's look more closely at those
unbiased estimators in matrix form
that's it pop up so it turns out volume
something is very closely connected to
this matrix to de inverse so to kind of
understand the setup here so we have a
tall matrix X and by D the rows are what
R is something we use the selection
matrix is to base
we construct matrix is X which zeros out
everything that we didn't sample right
so we have the same shape of matrix X
but everything else is U or not and then
we will look at this is x + matrix which
is the student versus X and think of it
as an estimator of the full student
versus of X just out this is an unbiased
estimator so the expectation and
expectation of this matrix estimator is
X plus is equal to X pseudo inverse
entry wise right so and on top of that
we can actually compute a matrix
variance of that pseudo inverse
estimator so here that this is sort of a
wone notion of matrix is one can
consider we basically square the
estimator matrix and then subtract the
square of the mean and we get an exact
formula which has this factor here which
decays with the subsets size which makes
sense device should go down and and this
I will not talk much about this but this
has interesting implication in sort of
experimental design and also in linear
regression have been a number of papers
that sort of used the variance of this
formula but in particular the unbiasness
of this estimator immediately implies
down bias not the least squares
estimator right we can just write
multiplied this is X plus matrix with a
vector Y so just to give you a sense of
kind of the proofs that we have here how
how do we go about showing this for
example this unbiasness property for for
the pseudo inverse matrix so let's let's
let's say that we want to show the the
expectation formula for the formula F so
so basically we want to show that under
say volume sampling expectation of F of
s which assigns some formula to any
subset s is equal to the value of F on
whole data set so we will use the fact
that volume sampling is closed under sub
something which means that if if say we
showed this formula for something of
size s then we can just
besides us and then sample down to size
s minus 1 and then just show that the
conditional expectation is preserved and
then by induction
the result Falls right so that's I mean
I'm kind of going over this quickly but
that's that's essentially the idea that
closure under subsampling is very useful
for these kinds of proofs and in fact
after that the the proof of the
pseudo-inverse expectation formula is
two lines yes so um you start so I mean
that's right that's right and in fact we
don't need to assume that this formula
computer yes so okay so so so what does
volume something do it samples a subset
proportionate to the probability of the
probability is the determinant of the
appropriate sub matrix so if the subset
is ranked efficient then the probability
is zero so you so you'll never sample so
basically a determinant of X's transpose
X s divided by normalization so as long
as the whole matrix is full rank that's
that's what I'm saying I guess I didn't
say that the full then for matrix this
has to be full rank or I mean that can
be fixed also but for now let's say that
for matrix is full rank but we will
never actually get to a subset that's
not full rank so so that issued never
rises I mean of course you have to be
careful when you write sort of the
inverses recognized right that's right
exactly that's right yes so so why are
we interested in these unbiased
estimators so like I said if you have an
unbiased estimator you can sort of boost
its performance by something several
independent copies of it and averaging
and in fact in this in this set up
you can just immediately see that if we
have an estimator that has an expected
loss pound and it's unbiased then the
average of K of those estimators will
have an expected loss bound that's a
fact of K better so that's kind of
useful and that exactly occurs when in
the case of volume something and it has
sort of interesting motivations in
ensemble methods distributed
optimization and and others so so
there's an interesting open problem that
arises here basically how do we get an
epsilon sort of relative error
approximation with a smallest number of
samples we made some progress on this
but still we conjecture that the do reps
on unbiased estimators possible sorry
yeah the over actual is known if you do
what again your sample see over you
basically prove is stronger and that's
true which requires mechanization of
like you prove that this I plus 1
symmetric polynomial over they are
symmetric polynomial which is exactly
what will show up here would be what is
the something you do you just do D of s
and volume just because I have lower
bounds for that so maybe maybe were
using different slightly different
notion but let's take it offline but it
sounds interesting definitely so so like
it's like there's a bias estimator
that's D over Epsilon
but the best unbiased estimator is
essentially deal of e / t over action so
difficult
I thought that was gonna be that if you
haven't sugar water for epsilon volume
samples this why doesn't know right it
does well so what that gives you is d
squared over epsilon just because the
factor so so we the result that we had
right so the result that we had was for
exactly size D volume sampling and the
thing is you would like to sample a
little bit more to get down to a
constant factor and then you can do
averaging to boost that by one over
epsilon coffee
so there's yeah you get exactly the same
as level of course on which she looked
across the over that looks exactly what
level for something that's right that's
it yeah exactly but you make so I'll
talk I mean if I get a chance I will
talk about it but you essentially can
correct the bias of levels or something
okay so let's talk about algorithms so
so again we come back to the fact that
volume sampling is closed under
subsampling and that immediately leads
to a natural algorithm where okay we
started a full data set and then we're
just going to down sample by one point
at a time so we down sampled by one to n
minus 1 and then we down sampled by
another one so each time you just have
to throw out one point and we just have
to figure out what is the conditional
probability at each time turns out we
can update the conditional probability
somewhat efficiency in sort of linear
time with the data set but that still
leads to the quadratic dependence on n
because we have to throw out a lot of
points so but actually this can be
improved and so I will not get into the
details but basically you can do
rejection something to avoid computing
the whole conditional probability and
that works remarkably well so it reduces
the runtime to n d squared which is sort
of somewhat satisfying because
essentially the first step of this
algorithm just computing X transpose X
and if you do that exactly that's
already an d squared so volume something
is only constant part on top of it here
ok so here's an interesting extension of
volume something which sort of connects
back to
a lot of the things that appeared at
this workshop so so we want to somehow
regularize volume something in such a
way that we can get away from the
dependence on the dimension D in fact in
volume something it's particularly sort
of important because you cannot sample
set smaller than ghee unless you regular
eyes at least in in this framework so
instead of using the simple determinant
which would be zero for sets less than D
you use the determinant Poisson
regularization and it turns out you can
recover very sort of good something
guarantees for a Ridge regression in
terms of the statistical dimension so
this is the standard statistical
dimension for red regression it was it
would be much smaller than the dimension
D whenever maybe the data is
approximately low rank or so forth and
you only need to sample D lambda the
statistical dimension many points with
volume something to get error bounds
which I'll not get into about their
provable error bounds here okay so so I
mentioned leverage volume something
briefly and it's sort of interesting
from the context of from the algorithmic
perspective and so the here's the basic
idea
it turns out if you sample enough IAD
leverage score samples then with high
probability that sample contains a
smaller volume sample which means that
if you sample enough points then you can
probably select the subset that's well
spread out but in fact we can do more
than that we can actually say if I
sample enough leverage go samples I can
sort of transform that sample using
rejection something in such a way where
it's exactly a volume sample and then
this all of the unbiasness properties
are coming through and again we could
use the down sampling the closure
property to say that now we can down
sample to
small size such as D and so the runtime
of this procedure so this is nice if we
had leverage course this is immediately
there's no dependence on n it's just
polynomial in D and of course computing
of computing leverage scores can be made
quite efficient so essentially this
gives us an N and G of x time plus polyb
time for volume something and one way to
think about it is that this procedure
basically corrects the bias the bias in
the least square solution for the
leverage or something right so okay so
that's so we talked about a bunch of
algorithms let's put this sort of in
context in practical context so there is
an example benchmark data set the best
VM data set how efficient can volume
something be so as a comparison we look
at how long does it take to compute
leverage scores so this is this all of
this including leverage course so it was
you know in sort of should be comparable
running times so that's pretty fast
right so it's not such a large data set
right so we would like to make volumes
ambient it's close to it right it's
clearly gonna be at least this much
because it's a more complex distribution
computing leverage course is just a
pre-processing step form
so the first algorithm was only last
year the first polynomial time algorithm
and it doesn't quite get efficient run
time in this case although this is only
a rough estimate I I wasn't patient
enough to run it but so so afterwards
and this was only asked to you and then
our first valiant of perversity of
something reduced it significantly but
still it's nowhere close to two level
scores right 24 hours not that practical
the first reversal our sampling now
we're in basically in the constant
factor from from computing leverage
right so that's pretty good so that
essentially as efficient but still that
constant factor is there for leverage
volume something actually the dominant
cost of the procedure is computing the
levites course
so I guess you could say that the
improvement in the efficiency of volume
something seems to be beating them more
slow so far and let's try to keep it
going
yes exactly yes
so that's an important point so you
still have to compute their laboratory
so that yeah it's a pre-processing step
for everything all of those methods
require approximately approximately
volume something right so okay so
there's so this is all for exact volume
sampling and and also the the
terminology here is a lot of fuzzy
there's two pints of volume something it
depends on which subset size you choose
for the subset sizes at most D there was
algorithm before then for the subset
sizes which we consider for linear
regression which is more than V there
was no algorithm until last year so yeah
that's important to clarify okay so so
we be sure that volume something is sort
of like a natural natural distribution
to look at now it appears to be quite
fast to run and it leads to those new
unbiased estimators and there's an just
a number of many open problems one that
I mentioned and sort of questions
related to it so you get those unbiased
estimators but what if you want to
introduce bias like with this
regularization right but you want to
control that bias right so that you know
what the bias is unlike for Levitt or
something for though there is also the
applications to distributed methods and
also something I didn't mention is the
Terminator point processes volumes
something in some sense is a determinate
Oh point process in a particular case
and the connections there are quite
interesting and here are the references
that that I mentioned throughout the
talk thank you
[Applause]
that's a good question so concentration
bounds are natural for IAD sampling once
since volume something you have this
dependence jointness so that's so raises
a challenge and makes it sort of less
natural to look at concentration bounds
but in fact you can show concentration
bounds for volume sampling which are for
being predict for the level two volume
something case that I mentioned that the
concentration bounds much they want for
leverage score something but so far we
are not able to prove any better
concentration balance no actually so
well that's a also a good point so so
what you're referring to is so there's
this family of joint distributions which
volume something that belonged to for
which you can show concentration bounds
I guess negatively associated with the
term and and so you can apply those
except in these tasks for like you know
something matrices typically what you
would like to have is matrix
concentration guarantees and these those
results do not transfer to matrix
concentration guarantees so that's
that's like a big open problem negative
associativity concentration bounds for
matrices that's okay teachers if your
matrix is rank deficient or particularly
your ex they take a matrix which is a
matrix difficult decay is similar values
let's say so can you do first a
dimensionality reduction and then look
at the volumes they're like let's say
you just you don't you don't the
determinant of the d by d matrix you
look at like a smaller like a k k
determinants there so is there any
result that shows you what is the
expectation of the loss if you just pick
let's say the first k singular single
bit vectors I'm not sure I mean I know
that there's results which say okay you
can you have your high dimensional
matrix you sketch it and then you do
volume something or this kind of thing
on it and then you can say that to some
degree this something is approximates
more or less accurately the sampling of
the from the original matrix therefore
you know maybe it's what using but those
are not very satisfactory because for
this to for this to work the sketching
is to preserve all of the determinants
of all of subsets which which can be
done but it requires sort of more it's
it has bigger error bounds and what you
would like ideally like so but and you
know so one direction towards that would
be some kind of a variant of this of
regularized volume something which we
started work on and but that there's
sort of yeah there's a lot of open
directions for if you have if dimension
D is large that argument the current
organs are not that efficient yet so
that's that's a open direction thank you
again
[Applause]